في السنوات الاخيره يبدو ومش يبدو يعني هو
في حديثه يقول ان معنا كان ربما ان حان
الوقت بان ننهي هذه الحلقه المفرغه
ولم يقع ذلك لان يبدو ان تمت الاتصالات
في لندن في فرنسا في غيرها من البلدان مع
بعض
ولكن
مسؤولين امنيين مختصين في في هذا الشان
وربما ان كان هناك همم ما اخذ في كل هذا
هو انه لم يعد بهذا الى
سياسي
او من
يستثيقه او من يرتئين يعني
الاغتصابونها باعتقادك الطريقه
القناه السياسيه ليست قناه
الاختصاصيين في شان الامني يعني هما هما
انجعوا الناس في جمع المعلومات والتقديمها
الى اخره وليكن ليس انجلو
الامن هذه المسؤوليات
هذا هذا ربما الجانب من جانب طبيعته
الشخصيه يعني سياسه او هذه الاشياء
السياسيه الاستراتيجيه يريد ان يعني
هو بالاساس يعني طبيعته عقليته تفكيره لا
يزال امني بالمعنى الامني والعسكري هو
باقي باقي دائما على علاقه متينه بما يجري
في وزاره الداخليه بانه جاء من وزاره
الداخليه الى الوزاره الاولى ثم من
الوزاره الاولى الى رئاسه الجمهوريه
ظل محافظا على تلك العلاقه مع الوزاره
الداخليه ولكن في نفس الوقت ايضا هنالك
يعني مؤسسات اخرى كالمؤسسه العسكريه وكان
تعرف ان النظام ان ذلك كان رئيس الجمهوريه
هو القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه واللي
يشرف عليه وزاره الدفاع بالتبيعه الحال
وكذلك كان همم كان لنا هيكل امني اسمه
والامن الرئاسي مستقل بقانون الاساسي الى
اخ مستقل حتى في اموره الاداريه يعني
مستقل حتى عندي وين الرئيس يعني كان مؤسسه
بحالها لها مديرها العام و لها قانون
وضوابتها الى اخره وهذا تغير بعد 2010
لم تعد الامور منظمه كما كانت ولكن كان
هنالك قدر ادنى كان يحافظ على استقرار
البلاد
قانونيه ومؤسستاتيه تمام